-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Common.
Now, I want to point this out
'cause this is the first
opportunity, obviously.
And I know this is not why...
You don't do the work
for the awards.
But you do have an Emmy,
you've got a Grammy,
you've got an Oscar.
That's the EGO.
-Yeah, I got a little --
a little EGO.
-You've got a little EGO.
But this is it, this is --
Now, you've thrown yourself --
your hat in the ring for a "T."
Would you be upset
if you had an EGOT?
[ Laughter ]
-I like the way you phrase that.
I mean, listen,
I'm very grateful
for just being on Broadway, man,
and to be a part of the theater
community itself.
That was -- that was a dream of
mine at some point,
and the fact that I'm actually
doing theater now
is just like...
I'm just in the spirit of that
and I'm trying to give my best
every night.
-So you really want it?
-Oh...
[ Laughter ]
Nah, nah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But this is the thing.
This is the thing.
For me, also,
it's like, every...
You know, what you just named,
which I'm super grateful
to have those awards
you just mentioned.
But every -- whether
I was doing music
or whether I was acting
in a film
or creating a song for a film,
I just went in it
with my heart and soul, man,
and put my spirit into it
and gave my best.
And whatever results happen,
that's icing on the cake.
Once you're done, you know if
they say you're in the running,
of course you're like,
"Okay, well..."
And to be recognized
by the peers of like...
To be recognized by people in
theater would be amazing feat,
but I'm just happy right now
that I'm on that stage
with Stephen McKinley Henderson,
who's just incredible.
-He's amazing.
He's been amazing forever.
-And this incredible cast doing
Stephen Adly Guirgis' play.
It's just like, man, this is
stuff like I dreamed of,
but I didn't know
I would be able to do it
with this group of people
and at this level.
So, just for people
to say, man --
my family to come see me on
Broadway.
Look, some of my family
had never -- some of my people
who came from Chicago
had never seen a play,
and they came to see
"Between Riverside and Crazy."
So that, right there,
you know, is an award.
That's a victory for me, yeah.
-You talk about your family.
I know you're close.
Your mom was your first business
manager, is that correct?
-Yeah, she was.
-How'd she do?
-Well, she was great initially
because, you know,
my mother's from Chicago,
and she was -- she's a teacher,
but she also did corporate work.
So she knew business
pretty well.
She got that Chicago hustle
in her, too.
So she was really good with
the business and made me --
and asked me to invest
in properties early.
But eventually, it started
to become like,
you know, your mother telling
you, "Aw, don't do that,
don't spend money
on this and that."
And the business manager went to
business damager after a minute.
[ Laughter ]
-How'd she take the news
when you --
When you moved on,
how 'd she take it?
-Aw, man, it was tough.
But, you know, when a mother
loves her son,
she gonna eventually say,
"Okay, it is what it is."
But now, she sees the business
is flourishing even more,
and she's doing the work with
my Common Ground Foundation
and having great
pajama parties now
birthday parties,
so she don't care about
the business like that no more,
long as the money is flowing.
-That's good.
That's good. The money's
flowing, she's happy.
-Yeah.
-You mentioned --
You mentioned she was honest
when you were Tiny Tim
in the second grade,
in your performance,
and I'm assuming
she's honest today.
Has she seen you on Broadway?
And what has she told you
about your performance so far?
-Yes, my mother brought 198
people to see the show.
[ Laughter ]
That's a real number.
-That's a lot --
That's a real number?!
-That's a real number.
-All in one night.
-I'll tell you,
my parents have asked me
for tickets before,
but never that many.
-198 people.
-My parents don't know
198 people.
-[ Laughs ] 198.
Well, and she loved it.
She came to opening night also.
And she's saying she may bring
back 150 for the last week.
[ Laughter ]
That being said, she told me
I did very good in the play.
She said --
but she said -- but she said...
She also said, "You will be
great eventually,
but right now,
you're very good."
[ Laughter ]
-That's a mom for you,
right there.
-That's a mom, yeah.
-That's the right kind of mom.
Common, everybody!
"Between Riverside and Crazy"
is playing at the Hayes Theater.
we'll be right back
with Jonathan Lemire.